I saw a super interesting headline this
morning about the U.S military and we've
talked about the U.S military so much on
this program it relates to foreign
policy it relates to budgetary
priorities it relates to culture in many
ways because there is this military
culture that exists in the United States
okay so what's the headline the headline
from the Army times is that the Army has
missed its recruiting goal by about 15
000 soldiers and as you read through the
article by Lolita balder from the
Associated Press you see that that 15
000 Soldier shortfall is about 25
percent of its recruitment gold this
year now at big companies when you miss
earnings projections by two percent it's
a pretty big deal so understand that
falling 25 short and the military is a
large organization falling 25 percent
short of your recruitment goal for a
year uh is a really really big deal the
um article also points out that all
military services struggled in what
they're describing as a tight jobs
Market to find young people both willing
and fit to enlist uh adding while the
Army was the only service that didn't
meet its Target all others had to dig
deep into their pool of delayed entry
applicants which will put them behind as
they begin the next recruiting year on
Saturday
um the article to its credit says the
worsening problem stirs debate about
whether America's fighting force should
be restructured or reduced in size if
the services can't recruit enough and
also puts added pressure on National
Guard and reserves to help meet Mission
requirements so there's actually a bunch
of interesting layers to this
conversation first of all is just the
question why aren't as many people as at
times past applying or are the people
applying not meeting the relatively
modest
um but but still there uh requirements
for joining the military when it comes
to physical fitness and and health
conditions and this sort of thing one
really interesting aspect to this is
that wages are up in many sectors
including sectors that could be
alternatives to joining the military and
if you look at a wage and salary growth
in the United States this is a chart
looking at the last 25 years you see
that basically dating back to sort of
early in 2020 the pandemic quite frankly
there has been significant wage growth
in the United States now there are those
who will say this is a good thing
because people are making more some on
the right who often criticize lack of of
wage growth when there's a Democratic
president now say the wage growth is bad
because it's part of inflation which is
making it hard to hire people the right
is going to say it's bad no matter what
if a Democrat is in office but let's be
quite Frank and direct about this
if you can make a better wage not
joining the military there are lots of
people who will choose to do the job
outside of the military or said a
different way when wages aren't as
oppressively low outside of the military
it's going to be bad for military
recruiting now there's also sort of
political reasons why folks might not be
jumping to sign up for the military at
this point in time look at someone like
Republican Congressman Matt Gates who
over the last week has been in a bunch
of viral video clips saying why don't we
get rid of the VA altogether the
Veterans Affairs Department
and of course you might believe that he
really wants to improve care for
veterans by getting rid of the VA and
doing it a different way but for the
most part veterans like the VA and it's
probably not helping recruiting that you
have even Republicans who are supposedly
always for the military and Veterans uh
openly hostile to some of the aspects of
uh of of the military World which
includes the VA
um and saying we should we should get
rid of that we have the stories of
female service members regularly
assaulted and worried that if they
report the assault within the military
they will be sent for a psych eval maybe
deemed unfit for service and they are
the ones who will Who will suffer rather
than the person they accuse of
assaulting them but that's just the kind
of nitty-gritty of why might we be
seeing this problem and of course you
can also make the claim although I don't
have data on
um that maybe
people who were targeted by the military
to join aren't seeing it as a valiant
Mission compared to at times past we
know recruiting after 9 11 went Sky High
because so many people thought if I join
the military now I'm going to be able to
do something to stop or hurt the people
that did 911 then they were sent to Iraq
which had nothing to do with 911 and the
rest is history but that's not the story
for today but there's a whole other
aspect to this which is it should make
us ask the question why does the
military need to be so big uh and we can
talk about big in terms of what it costs
but also huge militaries can cause
foreign policy blunders and we we've
seen this in the past if you look at
stories from the Korean War Vietnam to
some degree when you have a really big
military it can make one believe that it
is even more powerful and invulnerable
and you make military decisions that go
above and beyond even the power that you
have and it can lead to very bad
military decision decisions create
Quagmire's
endless uh sort of like a constant
rotation of loss of life it's kind of
what's happening to the Russian military
in Ukraine right now they do have the
stronger military but they overstated in
their own minds even the strength and so
there's lots of geopolitical reasons by
having a big military isn't necessarily
the best thing and of course if you're
someone like me a progressive Social
Democrat I want I'm not for abolishing
the military that I I recognize there
are threats to the United States the U.S
should have a military but it shouldn't
be nearly as large and far-reaching as
the one we have is and so much of the
money that is spent on defense could be
better spent elsewhere
I won't give you the full rant of all
the areas in which it could be spent but
I have many clips and stories about that
so needless to say the military
struggling to recruit what comes next
and and to be clear
this has nothing to do with Joe Biden
there are I saw anecdotally on Twitter
people saying this is because Biden has
disgraced the country so no one wants to
serve there's no evidence of that
whatsoever I also saw this is because of
Joe Biden's student loan debt relief
because one of the reasons people were
joining the military was because they
needed money to pay off their student
loans first of all that debt relief was
only just announced and that couldn't
possibly be the reason why in the last
year there was a shortfall in recruiting
uh and number two you're sort of saying
like we need to keep people really
desperate financially so that they'll
join the military that's not really that
doesn't speak wonders about the American
military if that's what it takes let me
know your thoughts I don't know that
this problem is going to Abate anytime
soon